what we're doing here is we're just
trying to evaluate this expression okay
you've got a trig function then you have
its inverse trig function and kind of
what we've been talking about when we
first introduced this is inverse
functions are meant to undo they meant
to sort of invert hence inverse whatever
operation is the inverse function right
so you kind of would expect or if you'd
have a number like say five and you
square it you get 25 and then you take
the square root which brings you back to
five right so you're like okay you do
the operation you do its inverse and you
land back where you started however we
already know from an example like that
while the square root of 5 squared is
sure enough equal to 5 that doesn't
always work out so neatly does it
sometimes for instance if you take a
number and then you apply an operation
and a function rather and then apply its
inverse you do not land back where you
started
yeah does that make sense in fact you're
like oh that's the opposite of what I
wanted why is that what is the problem
that this is okay with you do a function
in its inverse and you land back but
then sometimes you use something else
and you don't learn back there once you
have a theme can anyone tell me what the
issue is let me know you in the right
direction but I'm not gonna tell you
later I'm gonna look for you guys to
help me out here
it really has to do with this guy do you
remember when we were talking about this
function we drew it right Erica what do
you think okay so we've talked a lot
like from earlier years about when you
have a quadratic equation and when you
have like a plus or minus solution from
it right now this is not a quadratic
equation it's the square root of
something okay and so the square root
doesn't have a plus or minus attached to
it right it's a function one of things
about functions is you put one value in
and you get how many values out if it's
a function you get one that's what makes
it a function as opposed to a what's it
called sometimes you can put one value
in to get more we call them a relation
right we are talking about inverse
functions not investor relations okay
now more specifically the issue is that
this guy here we restrict it right it
only
a particular range what is the range of
the square root function like you can
think about what it looks like right
there's the graph look like
there it is what's the you can tell me
that what the range just look at the
picture
the range is it's going to be greater
than or equal to zero does that make
sense
so the range here is greater than or
equal to zero which is why it will never
output a value like negative five okay
now let's come all the way over here to
our inverse trig functions okay this guy
here like the square root function it
has a range what is the range of tan
inverse I think I heard it so again you
can think of the picture right there's
the picture that's what tan inverse
looks like we've seen this before now
and it goes from negative pi/2 all the
way up to play on tune right it's very
similar to the range of sine inverse
with one crucial difference negative pi
on to two pi on two if this is the
y-axis right the difference between tan
inverse of sine inverse is that what can
I get to these asymptotes can I ever
reach there and the answer is no so I've
got the boundaries excluded whereas in
sine inverse you have what you have at
the ends of the sine inverse graph what
do you put there what do you draw you
draw a closed a filled circle right
which means you can actually get two
naked plant to impound to okay so now we
started yet the issue right there is a
range restriction on tan inverse just
like there is a range restriction on the
square root function right and this guy
here five point six
where is five point six it's a not in
this range is it
there's pi on two which is ninety
degrees five point six is how many
degrees think I think we're gonna get
better at this you've got to be able to
convert back and forth in your head
that's 150 degrees yeah you're like what
no I'm Way up here okay so you see the
problem right so that's firstly the
reason why there's a discrepancy here
let me think you help you think about a
way to approach this which is um it's a
bit more visual than using the quadrants
so would you pick up your arm if you've
got a red pen with me draw a nice normal
set of axes just for your tan graph can
you do that
not telling us just the regular tan
graph and we need enough of this we need
enough of this graph to actually see the
five pile six that we're after okay so
I'm gonna draw this much of it okay so
here's regular tan yeah you with me now
what I want to do with you is help to
think through visually what I'd like
your what picture I'd like your mind to
call where you see this okay when this
comes into your mind I want a picture to
involuntarily appear just like when I
say dog you're like I can't not picture
a dog now you've got a dog in your mind
right I don't know what kind of dog it
is but you've got one there you can't
not picture it I want this to become the
reflex of your mind okay let's take it
one step at a time ten five and six I'm
going to start from the inside here why
do you think that is why I think about
this guy first before I get to that hmm
what do you learn about water vibrations
get back to you seven which kinds of
things do you do first you do what's at
the front of that acronym Bodnar's it's
it's brackets right so you're gonna
you're gonna look inside you look at the
deepest part of it and you say that's
what I'm gonna deal with first
okay so ten five play on six that's
going to give me you give me an angle
I'm gonna get a ratio out okay so where
is five pilot six on this graph can you
tell me where it is you can point to it
right where would you like me to go I'm
gonna I'm still gonna wait for this
because you guys can tell you can tell
me where five point six is right yeah
okay I can see a few of you I'm still
not most of you you have to start
thinking in radians right here's PI 180
degrees we already established that this
is a hundred and fifty some pretty close
over here are you okay with that right
so five point six that's where I'm going
to place it okay now reach for your
calculator for a moment what I want to
do is get a handle on what is this
actual value okay so when you put ten
five pounds six into your calculator
it'll spit back some weird decimal
rubbish right can you tell me what the
decimal rubbish is because I'm kind of
interested in what do you get negative
now before I write down the rest of the
numbers right you should be relieved
that you got a negative why look at the
graph why does it have to be negative
yeah yeah look at the spot that I'm on
right when you go oh look there's where
the graph is intersecting that's
negative sure enough thumbs up and there
was negative 5 7 7 7 da da da da okay so
you like yeah it's just a little bit
below the axis that's exactly what I
expected now some of you will be good
enough with your ratios that you can
tell me what the surd is for this right
don't yell it out just yet a lot of you
will not be good enough because you're
like my head is spinning with all of
these other things I'm trying to
remember so what's a nice way to find
out what this said is if you do not
remember so remember the little trick my
calculus knows from last year if you
take those if you square it right if you
square both sides
go ahead you've got your calculator
there right this is in the display you
just hit square and then what do you get
you get a third right now that's a bit
sneaky and cheap but what it does tell
you is that the previous line which is
the square root of that is going to be
103 except we know that negative there
right when we squared that we lost the
fact that it was negative but you wrote
that down you know that's what it is
so there let's move the zero out of the
way there's negative one on route 3 you
okay with that all right
so therefore what this really means is
what's tan inverse of negative 1 on
route 3 just pause for a second because
all of you have not quite got this some
idea in your head a regular trig ratio
trig function you put in an angle and
you get out a ratio yes
inverse trig does that in the opposite
direction you put in a ratio and you get
out an angle okay so whatever the answer
to this is it'll be an angle some PI on
whatever okay so I want you to have a
look on this graph there is an angle
that has exactly the same value that is
inside the domain I'm interested in
right can you see where it is
I've almost drawn all the way there
right
see a dotted line coming across there is
dot BAM that spot there whatever this
angle happens to be will have the same
will give me the same negative 103 that
I'm after okay and much better than the
previous angle it's inside this domain
that I'm interested in it's from
negative pi onto the pilot too okay so
the last thinking point now is well what
can I use about the property of this tan
graph to get from here to here what's
the difference what is this actual
distance in here no Tommy it's gonna be
PI radians why is it pi yeah the
wavelength or we'd talk in in in rather
than physical terms in mathematical
terms we take the period of tan is pi
radians right so therefore you just have
to rewind pi radians to get to there
which I think if I'm doing my numbers
right that's negative pi on 6 and that's
the answer that I'm after okay
now that takes a lot longer that
thinking process takes a lot longer than
just drawing a triangle or drawing some
quadrants okay
however can you see how much it helped
us to think about the inverse trig
functions and what they're doing it
helps you understand the graph better
you cannot escape the graphs so you
might as well invest the time now to
actually understand them better okay